hey guys it's vadim with maxtec and
welcome to our gaming review of the 16
core m1 pro macbook pro now as i've
already shown you in the previous gaming
review of the m1 max model with the 32
core gpu that is an absolute beast for
gaming but the question that we're gonna
answer in this review is how much worse
is the 16 core m1 pro and is it still a
good value if you're trying to do some
gaming so what i did is i went through
the old video and i literally took down
notes of the fps that we got with the 32
core m1 max and screenshots of all the
graphic settings and resolutions and i
am going to play the same games on this
16 core machine and show you guys actual
charts comparing the differences in fps
for the different games and methods that
i used to play the games so as you guys
can see right here i have crossover 21
open and i would say that this is
absolutely the best method for playing
windows games on your new m1 pro or m1
max macbook pro and the installation is
actually very easy you just download
crossover 21 then install the windows
version of steam and then you install
the dependencies like directx for modern
games and then enable dxvk within the
steam bottle and you're basically set to
go and play your favorite windows games
and the best part is that you get a 14
day free trial to test it out and when
you decide to buy it which i think you
will because it works so well it's 60
however we actually have a coupon code
max tech 25 which brings it down to only
45 dollars if you use our links so go
ahead use a link in the description or
the pinned comment for that discount and
i actually have a huge surprise for you
guys because within this video i'm
revealing our three winners of a one
year crossover 21 license key as you can
see in our previous video i announced it
and i'm gonna go through those comments
and pick out three lucky winners so
let's go ahead and do that now as you
can see i'm in comment picker.com i put
in the url filtering the duplicate users
and let's pick the first winner alright
there you go the first winner is eric
his comment said i want it well guess
what you just won a one-year
subscription to crossover 21 so
congratulations let's go ahead and pick
the next one there you go cyhunter psy
saying hope there will be more native
games next year yes i hope so as well so
i'm gonna reach out to you and for the
third winner let's see we have who
brecht i think who wrecked i just
purchased a m1 mac mini and really want
to win the giveaway congratulations
you just won the giveaway so if you see
this reach out and i'm going to try to
reach out to you as well and there you
go congrats guys on winning those
license keys and if you end up trying to
purchase it once again use the code
maxtac25 for 25 off your crossover
subscription so without further ado
let's jump right into the gaming and
before we get into grand theft auto 5
witcher 3 in other games like that i'm
going to start off with rocket league
and here we are in the settings and i've
matched up all the graphics settings to
exactly what i played with on the m1 max
32 core model so let's go ahead and test
out the fps that we're getting
yeah definitely doesn't feel like it did
on the m1 max where i was getting a 60
fps unfortunately i don't have a uh
fps counter still pretty smooth i mean
it's
definitely playable whoa a little bit
stuttering there so it feels like it
might be like i don't know 40 or 50. hey
get out of here
i mean if you're insanely competitive i
don't think you're gonna
want to play at these settings you're
gonna want to probably turn them down a
little bit more
yeah i'd say like 45.50 and now moving
on to the next game we have diablo 3
right here and this is actually a port
to mac os so it's running using rosetta
2 translation so it's not negative
performance so let's go ahead and test
it out before we get into it here are
the settings we're running at native
3.5 k resolution that's 16 by 10 for the
aspect ratio full screen high texture
quality medium shadows physics high high
full screen anti-aliasing so let's apply
accept these settings and let's get into
it all right now this is very
interesting i'm sitting at 88 85 fps
right here as we're walking through town
now i do want to mention right away that
on the 32 core m1 max we're actually
looking at a range between 124
to
164 fps in the town area so we're
definitely getting less fps and we're
not taking full advantage of the 120
hertz pro motion display that these new
macbook pros have so it's definitely
cutting down a little bit but as far as
the range is staying very consistent at
around 85 to 88 fps so it's still very
good guys i could definitely tell i'm
not getting as good fps
anymore just running through here 82
right now
but throughout the gameplay that i've
done so far
i think the lowest that i've seen was 62
while fighting and i feel like the heist
was around 88 or 90 while fighting as
well so
not too bad oh i just hit 58 right there
actually
50 55 fps
all right there you go i died well the
lowest i saw on the 6d core m1 pro was
55 fps to a high of around 88 now
comparing that to the m1 max i was
actually getting 95 to a high of 138
on the 32 core m1 max you're getting a
pretty big boost in graphics performance
in diablo 3 so i'd say it's definitely
worth it going for the m1 max at least
for this game and now on to the next
game we have starcraft 2 which is also
emulating x86 code using rosetta too so
let's start off by going into the
settings and here we are we got full
screen 3.5 k resolution once again i've
got graphics on custom i've set the
shaders to medium because if you go up
to high it basically ruins the fps like
crazy so i've set it to medium ultra
shadows ultra terrain ultra effects
ultra textures medium post-processing
extreme physics high models basically
there you go those are the settings that
i played with on the m1 max so let's
test it out all right so i've got my fps
counter and because this is 3.5 k res it
is so
tiny and hard to see but let me take a
look looks like we're getting a 51 fps
right now and it's staying pretty
consistent not too bad but definitely
not great now on the 32 core m1 max at
this point in the starting area i was
getting between 100 and 120 so it was
disappointing to be looking at 44 fps
right now
that is definitely disappointing and man
it's now down to 37. that is just so
weird
it's definitely not as optimized
with this m1 pro all right this is
really weird now that i'm not looking at
my base it's now up to a hundred and
twelve hundred seventeen fps
huge difference now look at this i'm on
my base with all my suvs goes down to 35
but now that i'm out in the open
now it's what 65.70 is ramping up slowly
90 over 100 now
i did not experience that
with
the 32 core all right now that i'm
fighting
looking at
40 fps man it is stuttering
this is not good guys 29
i just hit 29 while fighting these guys
it looks like we're getting between 29
and 50 55 fps while fighting now on the
32 core m1 max i was getting 90 to 95
while basically fighting in the
opponent's base which is a huge
improvement and it's above 60
such a massive difference between the 16
core and the 32
in starcraft 2. wow now in the last
video i also tried out 1920x1200 which
is a little bit higher resolution than
1080p
so let's do that on the 16 core
and see how much fps we get now so the
fps counter is a little bit bigger and
let's just do some fighting
now we're sitting at a much better frame
rate sitting at about 95 89 not bad 89
fps 97 i just got there
106. 108.
i guess now that all that stuff died so
it looks like between 90 and 100 with
these lower 1920 settings and that is
compared to
98 to 114
on the 32 core so it looks like we
didn't really gain that much on the 32
core by lowering the settings but we did
on this 16 core so keep that in mind
it's still pretty good if you just lower
those settings down on this machine and
i do want to mention that the fans are
literally idling during that gameplay so
you can't even hear the fans compared to
a lot of windows laptops which would be
blaring even in a game like starcraft 2.
and now switching over to a native game
yes this is built natively for arm 64
apple silicon world of warcraft let's
test it out now for the graphics
settings i'm matching it up once again
to the m1 max we got full screen native
resolution 3.5 k once again and i've set
the graphics quality to seven out of the
maximum 10. and right away i'm in the
same section as it was on the m1 max and
it looks like we're sitting at around 85
83 oh i just saw it dipped 79 fps it
just dipped to oh 77 i actually saw 77
fps to around
oh 75 fps i just saw it hit to a high of
85 in this section now the m1 max in
this exact spot with the same settings
we're sitting at
146 to 178
that is so much higher basically two
times more fps and that kind of makes
sense because it's fully optimized and
native and super super impressive in
this area now on the other machine i
also brought it up to graphics quality
10 so let's test it out on this machine
as well and right away i'm getting some
bad fps definitely some stuttering i
think i saw it hit 46 fps 45 fps right
there and i think the highest i saw
right now is 52 fps so this is obviously
unplayable especially if you're trying
to do
raids or anything like that so comparing
that fps to the m1 max we were actually
getting around 96 to 105
on the 32 core which is
definitely much better and then finally
and then finally the last thing i did
was put down the resolution to 1920 by
1240 and right now it looks like the
lowest that i've hit is about
94 fps and we are getting a little bit
over a hundred at times
which is good to see at around a little
bit higher than 1080p but we did oh look
at that 92 fps
we just hit a low up
and once again the m1 max was getting
between 160
and
180
during this so
honestly if you're playing world of
warcraft literally go for that 32 core
once again and now moving on to some
windows games let's jump right into
grand theft auto 5 we're using crossover
and we're actually using the nightly
beta build so it's not quite into the
public release yet but you can actually
go into crossover's website and then
sign up to be a beta tester and
basically play grand theft auto 5
including the online mode but pretty
soon i do expect it to be built into the
public release and there you go gta 5
let's run it and here we are once again
in the settings we actually have the
resolution to 1920 by 1200 a little bit
higher than 1080p because this is a more
tough game to run because we're going
through crossover so it's basically
translating vulcan into metal and it's
also using rosetta 2 to translate x86
code into mac os
arm native code which is a lot of
translation going on so that's why we
have that resolution and going down
we've got the texture set to very high
high on the shaders shadow quality
normal high normal normal normal sharp
basically you guys can screenshot that
or use those settings for yourself to
compare let's get into it here we are
and man this is not running well look at
all that stuttering
and the drop frames this is not running
anywhere close to 60 fps
oh and so much worse
than the 32 core m1 max
this is pretty bad oh look at all that
stuttering man this is
kind of hard to play
actually it feels like it's like i don't
know dipping down like 20 25 30 fps
probably somewhere between 20 and 30
most of the time sometimes it does
pretty well and it looks pretty smooth
but other times it just like
stutters and drops like crazy like that
there's no way you're gonna be playing
at these graphic settings you're gonna
have to turn them down now on the 32
core m1 max it was actually much more
playable it was sitting at between 50 to
55 fps and that's just my estimation
because unfortunately the fps counter is
not working through crossover steam for
some reason but it was much more smooth
almost a good solid 60 but this right
here between like i don't know 20 and 30
or something like that
it's much harder to play so what i did
last time on the m1x is i dropped the
resolution to 1280 by 800 dropping it
quite a lot to try to get some better
fps so let's do that right here
as you can see the graphics quality
pretty garbage and even still
even though it's a lot more smooth i
don't think
it's at a solid 60
because i am still getting some drop
frames here and there and it's just not
overall like super smooth so yeah this
is yeah pretty glitchy and we're
probably getting between like i don't
know 35 to 45 fps right now whereas on
the 32 core m1 max we were literally at
a solid
60 at least so it was perfectly playable
on that m1 max so honestly if you're
going to be doing crossover gameplay
with grand theft auto 5 i definitely
recommend going for that 32 core m1 max
for this game but the great thing about
crossover 21 is that grand theft auto
online is also working which is awesome
so let's get into that all right there
we go and oh my goodness look at those
drop frames yeah at these settings even
at 1280x800 it's still
not really playable man all right we're
doing some survival just like i did on
the m1 max in the last video and let's
see how much fps we get and surprisingly
it's still doing pretty good
around 35 to 45 fps
in a gta online with this machine
so still performing decently definitely
not super smooth whoa that was like a
drop weird drop frame there
oh man so here it looks like i'm getting
a pretty decent 35 to 40 compared to the
m1 max i was getting around 45 fps so
definitely a little bit better but not
perfect in gta online now before i get
into playing the witcher 3 i actually
want to open the mac os version of steam
where i have a couple more games like
counter strike go dota 2 and path of
exile so let's start out with dota 2
first here we are in the dota 2 settings
and we set it to 2560 by 1600 resolution
we've set the graphic settings to
literally maxed out all the way just
like i did for the m1 max in the
previous video so let's test it out all
right guys this is actually surprising
because this is the first game that i'm
not seeing that big of a difference the
lowest fps i saw so far just fighting
here in the beginning is 72 fps and the
highest is actually up to
a hundred the m1 max got between 98 and
117 so it's actually
not that big of a difference at all now
with that said in the last video i also
brought up the resolution all the way to
3.5 k
native res so i just switched to that
res and i want to test it out so now
that i've brought up the resolution it
didn't actually go down that much the
lowest i saw was about 59 to a high of
79 on this 16 core compared to the 32
core which was between 87 and around 95
so to be honest it looks like dota 2
isn't that well optimized and it's not
really taking advantage of the 32 core
m1 max like it should so i guess for
dota 2 the 16 core m1 pro is probably
fine and if you need a little bit more
fps just turn down the graphics settings
and you'll have no issues and our next
game is cs go this is wildly popular and
let's answer the question of if you can
play csgo on the 16 core m1 pro the
first thing we're going to do is once
again go into the graphics settings and
luckily we do have an fps counter which
is awesome so here you go here the
settings we're sitting at 1920 by 1200
resolution that's again higher than
1080p 16x10 going down the settings we
have medium for global shadows medium
for the textures there you go a lot of
these are set to medium so just scan
them for yourself right here and let's
get into the gameplay of course i'm
doing arms race because i love that mode
gotcha
oh stop
now so far this is actually performing
really well guys i'm surprised by this
16 core because it's doing really
decently now since this game gives us a
very wide range for the fps i'm gonna
split it up into two charts one for the
minimum fps that we see and one for the
high fps comparison to the m1 max now
the lowest fps i saw so far was 47 fps
for this 16 core compared to
fps on the 32 core m1 max so that's
actually nice because you're never going
below 60 whereas here you are going down
to 47 at a minimum
which actually i'm surprised by because
it's not that much worse than 62 so not
bad optimization for this 16 core
however on the high end this 16 core
looks like it got up to 101 fps at one
point compared to 129
on the 32 core now one thing i tested on
the 32 core was i actually brought up
the resolution to 2.5 k so 2560 by 1600
but i've turned down the advanced
settings down to low on most of the
settings so let's try it out on this
model all right and there you go our fps
counter just got a little bit smaller
now that we increased the resolution
up to 2.5 k now that's actually very
impressive resolution and not a lot of
people play cs go
that high but
let's test it out come on bro i know
you're coming here
i got you
whoo all right guys this is bizarre
because we're cranking up that
resolution
didn't really impact fps that much which
is super impressive so far and now with
the higher resolution i'm getting
between 44 and as high as 93 fps on this
machine which is super super impressive
compared to between 68 and 103 on the 32
core so this is crazy
well optimized and i'm impressed by this
m1 pro so i kind of feel like if you
bring the settings super way down you'll
be able to get away with playing cs go
on this 16 core
but if you want really consistent fps
above 60 you definitely want to go for
that 32 core and now moving on to the
next game that we're running under
rosetta
translation we have path of exile here
we are in the graphics settings we got a
lot of this set to default off for the
anti-aliasing shadow set to the default
ultra shadow quality high for the sun
shadow number of lights set to high
depth of field enabled high high 16
times texture filtering and basically
we've turned off the dynamic resolution
as well so it doesn't mess with it let's
see what we get and now that i'm
actually out here fighting the lowest
that i saw was 36
fps up to around 50. compared to the 32
core m1 max which is literally stuck at
60 fps all the time it never went below
60 so that's very interesting so
basically once again if you want that
perfect 60 gameplay you got to go for
that 32 core m1 max now i know a lot of
you guys are going to ask about the 24
core model and we have ordered that but
it was delayed so we're still waiting to
get that so hopefully within the next
week we're going to be getting that 24
quart model and oh my goodness this
guy's trying to kill me whoa kill him
boom
owned them so yeah we're definitely
going to test the 24 core so if you're
not already subscribed do so right now
because we're trying to hit a mill
before the end of the year and that
would really help us out and by the way
we got our new m1 max tech soc hoodie
which you can find in the merch shelf
below so if you appreciate all the
testing that we've been doing for the
past couple of weeks please support us
with that if you can and now for the
next game we have of course minecraft
we're playing this at native 3.5 k
resolution we've got the render distance
set to 10 chunks graphics on fast smooth
lighting on maximum clouds on fancy so
let's get into it alright so i've been
walking around in the demo and so far
the lowest fps i've seen is around 75
fps and i think it went up to around 120
so that is actually really impressive
because on the 32 core m1 max i got
between 76 as the low to 131
so even on this 16 core this game is
really well optimized either that or
maybe the m1 max is being taken full
advantage of because this is pretty good
fps for the settings that i'm using keep
in mind it's 3.5 k native resolution of
course this is minecraft incredibly easy
game to run but hey looks like you could
have some extra headroom to turn down
the resolution and install some mods if
you want to and there is actually a arm
native version which you can set up
there's a tutorial online that you can
find to get basically double the fps as
you're seeing right here so that is
pretty cool now moving on the next game
we have is the very popular league of
legends so let's see if the 16 core is
going to be just fine for this here we
are in league once again 3.5 k
resolution native all the graphics
settings maxed out all the way which is
pretty impressive and so far the lowest
fps i've seen while actually gaming and
fighting was 61
fps on this machine going up to as much
as
88 which is pretty impressive that's
compared to the m1 max 32 core which was
between 75 and 95
so even this 16 core is doing incredibly
well this is actually very impressive
and then when you're just walking around
like in base it actually goes up to 100
so at this native res
this is really good optimization for the
16 core and i would say that for league
of legends you absolutely do not need
the higher end
32 core m1 max because you have a lot of
room to turn down the resolution
to get better fps so that's really
impressive it didn't even go below 60.
and now going back to crossover 21 this
is a windows game the witcher 3 wild
hunt so here we are in the graphic
settings we're sitting at 1728 by 1080
resolution and we've turned down quite a
few of the settings down to low because
again we're going through crossover and
this is a pretty demanding game even
though it is a little bit old so let's
go ahead and jump in and start playing
all right unfortunately we don't have an
fps counter but man i'm getting so much
stuttering
and drop frames here
that man it seems like it might be like
kind of unplayable it's just
all over the place oh here we go oh this
is not gonna be easy
oh man so once you start getting into
fights man it's like oh no it's like
unplayable it's like stuttering it's
glitching
it is not good i don't know what it's
like like 30 to 40 fps or something
definitely not a good experience playing
the witcher 3 with the 16 core just
because of all the crossover stuff going
on so with that said i'd say this is
running at around 30 to maybe 35 fps
it's not good at all definitely stuttery
compared to on the 32 core m1 max we
were getting 45 to 50 so even though it
wasn't perfect 60 it was still
playable on the m1 max whereas this i
don't think it's playable with these
crazy low settings so there you guys go
and now that we got all of those games
out of the way let's answer the original
question is the 16 core m1 pro good
enough for gaming or should you go up to
that 32 core m1 max well first of all
i'd say that if you're doing any windows
gaming using crossovers or anything else
you've got to get the 32 core m1 max
because of all the translation going on
like vulcan to metal and then x86 to arm
with rosetta too
there's just so much going on that you
need the extra gpu performance for sure
now in a lot of the games that are more
optimized we did see a huge jump in
performance with the m1 max and it's
totally worth it if you're doing any
gameplay but there are a couple of games
like dota 2 or league of legends where
it just wasn't that big of a difference
going from the 16 to the 32 but even
still the m1 max was just that much
better to where you could get perfect 60
or higher fps in basically any game that
we tried so that is the sweet spot to
get perfectly consistent fps and in a
lot of the games you also get to take
advantage of the 120 hertz display
because you're reaching higher frame
rates so you can be more competitive but
either way if you are going to be
focusing on gaming definitely go for
that 32 core m1 max that's just my
opinion but if you're just more casual
and you don't mind turning down the
settings way low to get good fps then
the 16 core m1 pro should be fine but
for any windows gaming like crossover 21
definitely go for the m1 max so if
you're going to be doing that you can
use the promo code maxx25 to get 25 off
a one-year license for crossover 21
definitely do that so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and got some good
conclusions between those two machines
thanks for watching be sure to click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out the
original m1 match gaming review right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]